i would like to see that bring that back
back up
why did he have to what is he saving the
energy saving power yeah this feels so
like my energy bill is already through
the roof i know i know i'm getting some
vibes
kind of like an incursion but like a
realm-based encouragement yeah all right
we have our questions now empty we must
discuss this yes welcome back to new
rock stars miss marvel episode 4 deepens
the lore of realms in the mcu but how is
a realm different from a universe and
how universes suffer incursions when
they collide
why the hell do they keep using these
terms interchangeably when the same
executive producers are working on all
these titles seriously what is going on
this is inside marvel it's new rockstars
official after show for ms marvel on
disney plus i'm eric voss my easter egg
breakdown of this episode is going to
come out tomorrow right now i am here
reacting to this episode with mt
md
thoughts uh my thought is
oh no
the cabal is back in time what is she
gonna get out of this
sorry i just wanted to say oh no um yeah
i'm so
excited to see what happens to kamala as
she time travels and how she's going to
get back to the present like does she
have time traveling bracelets now like
what the heck's going on here yeah is
she back in the past is she in any
memory is she in a pocket reality what
exactly where exactly is she uh and and
what exactly does this mean that we have
this uh other
plane of existence that hovers over our
own reality uh and that we have these
dimensions realms that can bleed over in
our reality and it does sound a lot like
an incursion that we learned of in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness but how is this different from
an incursion are they the same thing i
don't think they are
but we will explore that let's first
recap what happens this episode kamala
and eva visit karachi pakistan uh miniva
it doesn't fully forgive kamala for
ruining her brother's wedding but
understands that it sounds like you know
sana is getting a bit old and wants to
do a visit we don't know how much time
has passed since the wedding it seems
like
at least a couple weeks you know have
passed um but we're not exactly sure at
the airport they're greeted by kamala's
grandmother sana hernani and her cousins
zaynab and oys and uh they go back to
their home they meet the dog magnum and
we only saw magnum for like
a couple seconds but empty we must
protect them at all yes
i love magnum this is the magnum show
now uh and we gotta pair up magnum with
lucky the pizza dog give them a spin off
because
i would love that
yes magnum pd for magnum
[Laughter]
i think most people just think magnum
police department if you were to make
themselves
true
no i would love to see two dogs as cops
that'd be amazing yes let's do it i mean
we just have to assume that magnum is a
scroll moving on no it's
my heart would break
can we also just talk about how big
sana's house is i mean they have some
money in that family uh or they're just
making some smart investments either way
this does feel like hmm like any time i
see a family that's really rich in a
movie now like
hmm okay
okay okay
you know and like there was that whole
subplot and they're paranoid paranormal
activity movies where the family was
just like kind of mysteriously wealthy
and he find out oh no that was a deal
that their grandmother had made with a
devil
that's most wealth eric that's most
wealth i i mean i'm now like calibrated
to where i whenever i see extreme wealth
that is not called out in a movie i just
i can't help but see that as an unusual
thing in this universe like uh i'm like
hmm how did you get that money i'm the
same way when i watched richie rich um
featuring kelly culkin but i'm like
blood money
what kind of exploited labor did the
rich family then uh
so many benefits so much
a lot of underpaid workers there um i
believe so sana shows kamala some old
photos from the partition era uh and
then she uh kamala tours the city and
visits the train station where she finds
this ant-man mural and then just gets
attacked by the red dagger kareem and
they have a fight now just so we're
clear with everyone watching this uh
they did go to another part of the world
to shoot this but they went to thailand
uh and there are some parts of thailand
that do have some uh some large muslim
communities that uh that i think they
were able to shoot some of the exteriors
here um i assume a lot of these
interiors including i assume this this
train station and a lot of the uh the
sets uh in the action scenes just for
all the stunts they had to rig were
probably built on a back lot and they
shot there um this ant-man mural
probably it was probably on a back line
so they they fight and uh they reach a
draw and he takes her to the red daggers
hideout behind a chinese restaurant with
this this hidden uh oven
switch right where it just goes back
into the wall that's how i get into my
bedroom i have an oven outside of my
door
and you just like pick up some chinese
takeout on your way in hey this is like
the best type of existence i would love
to live in that place it's like no one
will bother me because no one knows
where i am behind the stove
except the clandestine somehow yes but
uh she meets
she meets walid in this place this actor
is great and uh he explains that the
clandestine and aisha come from a realm
connected to earth but it is hidden from
us and is separated from earth by the
veil of nor and then uh if the
clandestines use a bangle to knock down
this veil the other realm will spill
into our world and just wipe it out
or maybe just karachi but i assume he
means the our entire world yeah um and
then kamalas spend some time with kareem
she eats baghdarani on a beach bonfire
we gotta say kamala in this show
cleaning up with the fellas
yeah she can really pick up his eyes for
kamala
it is now turned into a three a
three-way race for kamala's heart
between uh bruno cameron and kareem who
will win it by the end of this series
because he knows
i hope magnum wins he deserves to win he
does he's the best he's the best boy on
this show i so far so far he could do no
wrong magnum we could do no wrong
seriously um so meanwhile the
clandestine are taken to the dodc super
max prison this is the same prison we
saw in the she-hulk trailer where
abomination is being kept this is the
one in the desert that we speculate it
could be based on the cube from the
comics which is a super prison kep where
they keep gamma irradiated with super
prisoners um and it is like a shield
black site that becomes like the base of
operations for the thunderbolts in the
future
i don't know about that now because the
clandestines are able to break out of
this place
shockingly easy
even more shockingly are able to
transport to karachi exactly where
kamala is
now yes they sensed her nor in the way
that the the red dagger able to censor
that seems to be that it's just really
fast nashville drops in like surprise
[ __ ]
surprised to fight scene
okay okay and they fight and uh i gotta
say empty i am still every bit as
confused by and unimpressed with the
clandestine's power set i don't
understand
what is that i don't know what's going
on there i think they're they're strong
enough to like crack walls but like they
also use weapons i'm like i don't really
know
what's going on here in particular but
they can be stabbed they have some
hidden nor light magic within them but
it can't be activated unless they have
like a local bangle like
uh it's like having you need the sim
card of the country that you're in in
order to use your phone i guess there's
a logic there either way i'm going to
start calling them the yawn at this time
oh i think they're the only ones
the most forced and lamest and cringiest
uh pun
nickname i will come up with a better
one if i'm gonna start trashing them
like that i'm sorry i just don't care
like i'm i'm fascinated by where they
come from this glowing realm in this map
i am fascinated but them and their
stupid weapons pass hard pass i don't
yeah i i definitely agree that like
these guys could could have been more
fleshed out i did like that moment where
cameron was on the ground and they were
like oh man is he okay even though he
betrayed us like i did like that sort of
human moment there but like for the most
part
um it just they feel very flat but did
you like it when they immediately
abandoned him
and then cameron was like i can stand on
my two feet like what if camera just
wants to follow them he seems to be okay
to stand there he's like i'm too tired
to continue like i mean one thing he was
like bleeding out on the floor or
something like that but he's like if you
guys could just walk a little slow i
could keep up with you like no we're
gonna walk at a pace of
like a hundred miles an hour to make it
over to karachi right now
and if you can't move that fast they
aren't speedsters though did they just
take did they travel
commercially
did they take
did they take an uh american airlines to
get over and they they transferred in
berlin like how did they get there i'm
wondering how they got to myself because
that's a very valid point did they have
to go through tsa security like what
like what happened
that they went through the quantum realm
and then they just went and they pushed
your portal to the other side
okay
that makes sense yes i'll go with you on
that i think that is more like a clue
i mean look i think we were talking a
little bit uh before this recording i'm
not gonna say everything we said but i
will say that like it seems like there
was a lot edited down in all the scenes
with the clandestines you'll notice that
those scenes are just edited like crazy
it seems like they cut out all their
dialogues they cut back and forth
between characters i think there was a
lot of dialogue that was happening i
wouldn't be surprised if there was
another character in that scene they
just edited it out it seems like
this is like a compromise edit that we
are at right and uh they cut it down
just to the bare logic of what happens a
b and c in this scene and then we move
on and hopefully people are watching
this late at night on disney plus and
they just aren't going to question it
and they'll just be so charmed by other
things in the show and i'll say so far i
am very charmed by most other things in
this show so i'm not going to complain
that much i have complained quite a bit
right now so i'm going to just do fine
uh no we we do love this show a lot the
show is really great but like we do
the actual
villains
are kind of flat i do like najma i'm
very interested to see what najma and
like her ties to kamala are but like
everyone else the rest of the squad i
don't know i just it's kind of i'm not
even that interested in najma i got to
say it not even
i'm intrigued to see like what her past
is but like other than that i guess i'll
i guess i'll say i'm intrigued by this
partition past
i think it's fascinating i'm so glad
that this series is focusing on that i
think that's really cool um and and
heartbreaking and awesome that the mcu
can do this and like they're sort of
going with the whole partition theme
thematically with the whole like barrier
in the veil and like the two parts and
the two worlds that's right i think
that's one of the coolest things uh the
fact that like political boundaries are
so arbitrary and just set by people who
have no real stake in the present uh at
all and they're just there and then now
we see this other map superimposed over
it it's just like no all the political
boundaries on earth are just arbitrary i
think that is so cool i love i love them
um but we end this episode with this
chase through the streets of karachi it
ends with waleed and some of the
clandestines stabbed we think they're
all dead i think maybe they'll you know
just recover because you know so on
obi-wan
but um but najma's uh stabs the bangle
and it seems to break the bangle a
little bit and it sends kamala backward
through a portal and kamala finds
herself at that train station in 1947
the night sonic got separated from aisha
and it is heartbreaking to see all this
chaos it's just a sprawling desperate
panic as people are trying to board
trains to get out of there and that's
where we end this episode it's it's an
insane shot and i like i love that this
episode is going to this place um and uh
we'll talk about where kamala goes from
here but i think at the moment we got to
talk about this map of the realms how it
intersects with earth how these realms
connect with other things mentioned in
the mcu so far like the alternate
universes of the multiverse things like
the nine realms the thor mythology
places like tallow and chongqi the
ancestral plain of black panther the
duwood underworld valhalla of thor
we're gonna explain it all we got you
covered because i don't know marvel
studios world building apparently is
just like we'll let the youtubers handle
this and we're happy to pick up that
challenge and do our best yes before we
dive in just a reminder that new
rockstars is going to be live in austin
on july 1st through july 3rd for rtx
it's rooster teeth's podcast festival
our live show will be saturday july 2nd
it's just gonna be a lot of fun click
the link in the description use the
promo code new rockstars all one word
for a discounted ticket price we hope to
see you there also our merch partners
still have a limited number of ms marvel
inspired latest obsession shirts cosmic
daydream available at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's the best way
to support us here at new rockstars and
when you get one of these you will
unlock the added option right in a
custom shout out that will appear at the
bottom of these after shows for example
tola says do you think they will use the
term inhumans by the end of ms marvel
um
let's see uh i'm going to say after this
episode we only have so many episodes
left if they were going to do it on this
show i feel like they would have done it
sooner rather than later
so it's not going to be connected to the
clandestines but the bengal like we
still don't know the extraterrestrial
origin of the bengal right so i'm going
to say at this point
i'm going to place the odds that there
is a 40 chance that they say in humans i
think it's more likely to happen in the
marvels because like that seems like it
might be more cree related because of um
the way captain marvel one ended so like
i would say maybe the marvels but like
maybe not this one i think they're just
more focused on um this clandestine and
alternate realm type of deal there like
i think there will be a twist with like
cree and carol danvers and that kind of
thing like i expect that might be the
the big finale cameo or something like
that but
usually these marvel shows episode five
starts to reveal something you know uh
or the penultimate episode like we
learned that uh it was agatha all along
going into the third act so if we are
now like going from
four to five this is remember the end of
four in moon night was when we learned
that he was in a psychiatric hospital
and in episode five they revealed the
duat and that this is all part of the
egyptian underworld so like yeah next
episode where they'd be they would have
to reveal it there and i'm not i'm not
counting it out i just
i don't have high expectations but we'll
see we'll see yeah this next episode
definitely feels like the like all right
we're going to be back in time this
episode and by the end of this next
episode we're going to be in the future
again in the present day and then we're
gonna get the clandestines and like wrap
it up um so yeah i think that this is
it's not gonna i think there's not
enough time to introduce inhuman stuff
mariah says eric babe we both want it to
be mephisto but we know they won't give
it to us this soon hashtag still m train
uh yeah i don't think you're gonna give
us mephisto and ms marvel no way jose i
don't think so it's just coming
eventually but like not miss marvel he's
here he's already here he's your second
set
of the footprints in the blood
[Laughter]
emily says my fourth latest obsession
t-shirt thanks new rockstars for being
rock stars well thank you emily for
supporting us by collecting these shirts
emily we love you thank you emily thank
you so much it's very sweet of you and
we want to thank everyone who who bought
one of these shirts and is supporting
the channel like this we'd love you all
it helps us out so much we love you guys
yes it does all right mt what is uh the
conversation we're having this week all
right bro what are the hidden realms and
how are realms different from universes
in the mcu yes so wally shows kamala a
map of the world and then over it he
superimposes another map showing
different borders representing these
realms that are connected to our planet
but are hidden now uh do each of these
borders represent a realm we don't know
because he he dialed the knob as if if
we continue to twist it there would be
another realm that was superimposed and
then another realm so the the teal color
might just represent one realm that is
basically the size of earth but he uses
the term realm
and we can't see these borders that well
but they do these realms do exist all
around us on some other plane
it's kind of hard to tell from the shop
where the border lines compare to our
political borders uh because we do see
it from an angle not straight on from
waleed's angle but there are just
massive chunks of like what looks like
land masses hovering over the asian
continent of the african continent
irrespective of any ocean borders or
tectonic plates from our world uh but
the we don't really see any uh
alignment on sites of significance from
the mcu like wakanda or new asgard but
again it's just kind of hard to tell
from this angle and walid says there are
many dimensions around us that we cannot
see he said the home realm of aisha and
the clandestine is hidden from beyond
the veil of nor and that if the
clandestines use the bengal to knock it
down that realm will spill into ours
wiping out our world reminding us a lot
of the uh the incursions the way that
was talked about in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness this might be
just another way to describe incursions
or it might be something else
aisha's home realm is depicted to be a
glowing land mass made of nor light with
tall organic columns and a tree and all
of these taller far taller than
buildings compared to the karachi side
and we're going to keep having to do
this more and more as mcu titles come
out and throw all these terms around
loosely but let's just do our best to
define these things and how they're
different so a universe from what we
understand refers to separate realities
within a multiverse so we have the main
616 universe we have the 838 universe
etc each universe is parallel but
different having their own uh each
universe has its own doctor strange its
own avengers its own wanda maximoff they
they're supposed to look like
our our realities just like have some
kind of variations to them now
multiverse of madness did make this a
little confusing because uh while when
they were crashing through the different
universes a lot of them even the
honeycomb reality did kind of look like
a cityscape uh the the tube world with
the drones looked like a building
cityscape the bone world looked like
that that corner of manhattan just made
of bones yeah i think that they're just
tumbling through different variant new
yorks i think that that's what that was
happening there yeah absolutely so i
think that's the idea is that like it it
all still is what it is it's just kind
of made of different things slightly uh
or drastically uh and the way universes
are navigated is you have to either be
american chavez or you have to be able
to dreamwalk with a darkhold as like
wanda maximoff and dr strange did or you
gotta be someone like a watcher someone
who can transcend realities
but they haven't yet
they said wanda was a nexus being or
implied that um but it didn't seem like
she was a nexus being until she used the
dark holes uh because like it seems like
any sorcerer if they can use the dark
hole they can dreamwalk actively
dreamwalk into someone else's body also
multiverse madness implied that every
time we dream we are kind of navigating
the multiverse we're at least seeing
we're not controlling our other cells
that we're seeing through them now how
does that compare to a timeline i don't
know but let's try it the timeline's a
bit more confusing coming out of loki
but a timeline has been defined as one
causal loop of historical events one
after the other and it seems like it
seems like we don't know yet but it
seems like each universe has one
timeline threading through it
potentially looping through it and
forming a coil that's very confusing i
understand just go with me when a nexus
event occurs that timeline branches into
a variant timeline creating a separate
universe we think
so timeline in the universe are vaguely
similar but they just refer to kind of
different
ways where different contexts so
universe refers to like the setting the
ecosystem the the environment of people
and places within that world a timeline
refers to
the causal
events the his the history uh one event
led to this event led to this event
within that universe we think so a realm
a realm seems to be uh referring to
something that's more nebulous and
ethereal so as opposed to a separate
universe that looks like a doppelganger
to our world a realm seems to be a
surreal or a fantastical setting that
exists on a separate plane that like
floats above or alongside or below earth
it's not accessed by like wanda style
dreamwalking because it's not like there
is an alternate wanda in these realms
they are populated by completely
different civilizations by
interdimensional beings so just to give
some examples of realms in the mcu we
got the nord dimension now that we're
starting to explore in moon knight but
also we have the quantum realm and we
know there's a civilization in the
quantum realm remember we saw that
spherical bubble city we know of tallow
and chongqi and the realms beyond tallow
where the dweller and the darkness came
from remember nan started to explain
these these are completely different
dimensions and realms that don't contain
like variant christine palmers or
anything like that completely different
people we haven't met yet and then uh
presumably there's the gap junction in
multiverse of madness because christine
called that the space between universes
and i think that's what realms are
they're kind of a buffer zone between
universes where other civilizations can
flourish and live so i think it's it's
kind of i would love if the mcu gives us
more maps like this but i want to see
like a three-dimensional
four-dimensional multiverse map just to
show how all these universes are
connected multiverse of madness started
to do that by these red depictions of
these like little vignettes of these
moments but they were only just like the
moments but like if that could refer to
different universes and the way
universes are splayed out i just need
some objectivity like a kind of textbook
explanation and multiverse madness
remember reed richards had that whole
speech explaining what incursions are
and
almost word for word taken from john
hickman's 2013 new adventures comics but
the one thing that made that difference
different is we literally in those pages
saw
a
a
illustration
a diagram yeah and like why can't you
just give us that in the mcu why are you
just letting these people's words
especially if your words are going to be
interchangeable like you use the term
dimension to refer to like four
different things in the mcu and it's
just getting so confusing and i would
forgive it if it's like well there's
completely different uh directors and
writers working on these no you have you
have these executive producers uh who
are working on all of these who are
directly underneath kevin feige who are
there in the writers rooms on these
shows to ensure continuity and you've
been so good about it in the past it
just seems like there is not a plan and
that is okay but i feel like there there
is also a chance that this could all be
intentional as well because i feel like
um like we saw in the episode like uh
they're talking about jin and how like
he's like yeah like if thor came here
he'd be collagen i think it's all just
words really depending on what your
perspective is i think you're saying
what rocket said all words are made up
all words are being made up really but
yeah no it's just like hey i think so
like there's people in pakistan they're
probably viewing um this the nord
dimension as like a different realm
because like that's the way that they
see it's like all right this is a new
realm but like maybe um i don't know a
selvig would be like oh this is a
different universe because like i have a
different science perspective so i think
that because the mcu is becoming bigger
and um you know like with different
parts of the world i feel like there's
going to be different terminologies for
a lot of the same things and so like
what it could just be the case of like
marvel studios wants to trick people so
that they don't want us to get hip as to
what they're doing
so it's just like all right we're going
to call things dimensions and realms
it's all the same difference but like
we're just going to throw different
words around see i think they're being
intentional with like uh
why they're using different words i
don't think they used realms a lot in
multiverse of madness they used the term
universe they didn't use realm a lot and
what if they use the term universe
because i think they wanted to draw a
contrast between what these things are i
think so realms i think we can compare
to uh what planes are so the ancestral
plane right and the duat underworld and
moon knight i think these are both
realms i think in thor we've heard
mentions of valhalla right and that's
the place where the asgardians go when
they die in battle i think these are all
considered realms not universes so
realms seem to be intertwined with
spiritual beliefs right so if heaven or
hell ever introduced in the mcu or if
one of those fiery realities we saw in
multiverse madness are
as hell i think they're going to be
considered realms um now here is a
question we should ask we don't know if
each universe has its own set of realms
or if realms are really independent of
the multiverse and each universe feeds
into the same shared realms i think it's
the latter i think it's that because i
think the best way to look at these
realms are they are literally between
universes between parallel universes and
that they uh because they are between
universes all universes share them in
some way or they share borders with them
because really otherwise i think no one
watching these shows are gonna be able
to handle a six one six nor dimension
versus an eight three eight more
dimension that's just way too
complicated if anything we gotta turn to
the pages of agents of shield for this
because remember they said the quantum
realm was a nexus space between
timelines meaning
realms might be universe independent i
think that's a that's the way i choose
to look at it right now now how does
this connect with the nine realms of the
thor movies well we have to remember
those nine realms are not realms the way
we're describing them now they're
actually really like planets they're
heavenly bodies
that are interconnected by aegis still
that's just the way they kind of chart
out their cosmos their star map so
midgard is really just their word for
earth asgard is depicted as a floating
disk of space that can just be you can
get there just by flying to it in space
because the asgards flowed away from it
we have sverchulheim muspelheim
yotenheim nidavalier all these are
physical places that you can just travel
to in space in a single universe it just
feels like districts of space really yes
yeah it's it's on the same map that like
the cree map of
holla is you know so uh what are they
referring to whenever they say worlds
and dimensions so far marvel seems to be
using those words interchangeably to
just help explain the context of each of
these terms dimension has been used
often describe a realm even in this
episode they call it a dimension uh but
dimension has been also used
synonymously with universe and
multiverse of madness like dimension 838
dimension 616. uh and so is the word
world really with all of these terms
it's just about the context of the
present story so what is the context of
ms marvel i think the nord dimension is
a realm i think it is a realm between
universes and i think uh this is
stronger evidence that it's part of the
same kind of realm network as what we
saw tallow being in chiang chi the
realms beyond it that non referred to
the ancestral plane the duat valhalla
the quantum realm the quantum realm had
a civilization in it that we're likely
going to see in quantum mania the north
dimension has a civilization in it that
it are not variants of earth they're
another
race another uh group of beings now uh
this threat of this veil coming down i
don't know if it's gonna be connected
with the the incursions that are
happening around the universe i'm going
to assume yes but i think incursions
refer to two universes colliding but i
think those two universes uh that
process of the universe is colliding are
sped up when the buffer regions between
those universes are weakened and those
and those walls are weakened and i think
that's what we're seeing of with the
north dimension the veil of nor
i think is is under threat especially
because incursions are occurring across
uh the universes so uh if you imagine if
there's no buffer zone between things uh
it allows friction between universes to
escalate whenever we i mean i feel like
we're gonna we're gonna see the doors
open a little bit in the in the finale
uh i feel it's probably gonna look like
uh a lot like
the the when the dark dimension was
creeping through at the end of doctor
strange one and we if we see it briefly
in the sky but like we just see like the
the sky opening up and we see like the
portal to the dark dimension i have a
feeling that'll probably look a lot like
that because like i feel like that's the
only the closest that we've gotten to um
something like that happening because
the dark dimension was going to spill
into our reality and take it over
essentially so like i feel like this is
sort of another type of situation there
but that's just a guess yeah i think
you're right empty i think the dark
dimension is another example of these
kind of realms like right whenever uh
there's like a space in the mcu that has
just like weird topography and
architecture and plant life and terrain
that just doesn't look anything like our
world at all it's not parallel then i
think that is meant to be seen as a
realm that's and realms in some ways are
even more exciting like i'm more excited
to explore realms than i am alternating
universes because ultra universe is like
okay yeah we've seen multiverse fiction
done plenty of times rick and morty
sliders you know but uh
but i think realms is kind of like okay
well it's like a completely other
dimension with with other stuff other
people in it well i'm all for weird [ __ ]
eric so like bring it on yeah you can
get weirder with with other realms so
yeah while i don't think this is the
same thing as an incursion i think it is
still connected to incursions happening
ultimately right but hold on let me ask
you a question though but like who do
you think that these like norian people
are like do they want their universe to
spill on over to earth or like do they
even know that we exist yeah that's a
good question to ask if they know that
we exist i don't know but uh i think
that here's gonna be my theory on this i
think the clandestines want that
spillage to happen i think the people in
this universe are happy to live their
own separate light so these people kind
of like the uh ronin to the cree right
are imperialists they want to uh impose
their values their will
it sounds like zod right like we we
should be proud of who we are we should
conquer everything uh so i think
that's who the clandestines are they
were outcasts for for wanting to uh
but i guess the question is why would
they outcast people in this victimized
other realm of our realm uh i don't know
maybe they thought they killed them the
way that they thought they killed zod uh
and yeah i just happened to be freed
from a from a nuclear blast right it's
like all right we're gonna here's a
portal opening to an unknown dimension
we're gonna push
you in by as a punishment hopefully you
go to hell but
then they just went to earth it's like
all right this is sort of like hell yeah
for sure yeah i think it's hell honestly
yeah i'm telling you footprints and
blood
i think like um maybe they were at war
with a different realm maybe one of the
realms of tallow maybe the uh the
dimension where the dweller and darkness
came from i think all these folks are
completely okay living in their own
realms and not ever connecting with the
earth realm
but uh that there's some people in there
like no we should invade these we should
uh terraform it we should make it our
own
and then they get punished and then now
that's their plot is to like uh erase
the boundary between them so yeah i i'm
gonna imagine that most people in realms
are not going to be evil and horrible
because that'd be awful but i think
there's going to be bad actors within
all of those other realms or scripture
i guess we'll see we'll see we shall see
now we have a few more questions that we
want to talk about from this episode but
before we dive into those we want to
thank some friends who helped sponsor
this episode starting with our friends
at helix sleep thanks to hilac sleep for
sponsoring this episode of inside marvel
i sleep on a helix mattress and it's
just what i need after a night of
staying up to watch ms marvel helix
sleep is a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and your sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress made for somebody
else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way that you sleep everybody is
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains even
a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers helix was offered the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq in wired magazine helix has been
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to helix
sleep.com inside marvel take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com
inside marvel we also want to thank
athletic greens for sponsoring this
episode are you looking for a simple way
to get an all-in-one nutritional
insurance with one scoop of ag-1 you are
absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals whole food source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens to help you
start your day right this special blend
of ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system and your immune
system our very own tommy bechdold and
the rest of the break room crews started
adding ag-1 to their daily routine and
they have been loving it tommy says it
tastes great and it's easy to drink
first thing in the morning ag-1 supports
mental clarity and alertness as well as
better sleep quality and recovery and
for every purchase they donate to
organizations helping to get nutritious
food to kids in need including no kid
hungry here in the u.s reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop of ag-1 and a cup of water every
day to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and 5
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you got to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
marvel again that's athleticgreens.com
marvel to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance all right mt i
want to ask you about this dodc super
max prison this is the same prison that
we're going to see abomination inside of
in she-hulk why do you think it was so
easy to break out of
and who else do you think is in this
prison you know i i would like to think
that um they were on their way to the
prison like they were in the underground
tunnel like almost about to get to the
prison but they didn't quite get there
but like yeah it was so weird that they
were able to even break out or for that
their guards were just so
incompetent and just like it was just
very odd but like
i think that you know the deal this
could just be a case of the dodc just
being a new newer institution and like
they're trying to be shield but they're
not quite there but not quite there yet
and their um their force is probably
consisted of like just people that
aren't as trained because like we saw
that dude that soldier guy being a
douche so just like i don't know the
dodc just doesn't seem as put together
as shield quite yet but they want to be
shielded so badly yeah i think it's
probably it's they're just new but i
mean even with shield even with the raft
every prison that we see in these
universes is meant to be broken out of
that's just kind of the case
and arkham in the batman comics arkham
is always broken out of it's basically a
shelf where we put our villains for next
time
yeah it's just a set piece so that you
can break out of some cool looking
prison that's just that's always the
reality of it but i like your take that
they're not in there yet yeah this is um
because i'm curious because if like
they're able to keep abomination in
there an abomination is gamma radiated
and can like break out of anything you
think they because i think it just again
comes back to the question of i don't i
don't know what the clandestines can do
what they're capable of like they can
get arrested like if they could break
out of where they were there don't you
think they could have gotten out of like
the prison
transporter they could have like you
know shaken away from the guards who
were just kind of like
strong-arming them away from that hotel
like i feel like that escape scene could
have been a really great way to showcase
like all right here's how powerful we
are here's where our power comes from
and like
here's how we can break out versus like
all right
um we just got an opportunity we punched
the guy we escaped like it just i don't
know i feel like there's a missed
opportunity there hey it looks like
they're having a great time mtv i think
that's all i like that adam guy oh he's
got a big smile on his face he loves
carrying around that maze he's having a
blast and i don't want my criticism to
take away from his fun at the end of the
day yeah he's loving being in this show
they're parkouring over carts why hey
you know you do you
like yeah like i'm not i don't like we
don't mean to like you know disrespect
these people like they're doing a really
great job for like
what they're doing i just wish that we
saw more of their personalities i guess
is what i'm saying and like they had
more of a i want to get to know them a
bit more yeah right because like they
seem very interesting it's like we're
almost there but like we just haven't
gotten there yet it's like please
um like flesh these characters out a
little bit um what year mt do you think
the vault will be open on these things
is it gonna take marvel studios to like
crash and burn at some point in the
future for us to get the real stories on
how these shows are put together like we
still don't know exactly what happened
on uh
on the falcon the winter soldier no one
will admit to it because it's still part
of a living breathing universe and to
admit any mistakes were made it's like
like they admit mistakes were made on
thor thor the dark world but like any
time in the same sentence always be like
but we brought back all this stuff from
through the dark world and we told more
story about it and we kind of gave more
context so it actually was really great
like
like they won't really talk about the
recasting a whole lot from uh ed norton
to mark ruffalo they just kind of move
on past it like
i'm just i want to know how these things
were made not because i want to hate on
it but i just want to like i love to
know how the sausage gets made because
it shows how hard it is to make the
sausage and how impressed we are that
you were able to get this made at all
um yeah like i hope that like you know
like a decade down the line or something
we get a documentary or something like
that just like all right the making of
the mcu in full like here's everything
because i would love to see that
personally because like you said i love
seeing how the sausage gets made and um
you know it just at the marvel studios
is like a really intricate operation so
like i just i just want to see how that
whole operation runs and like in the
little the messy parts of it too i wanna
yeah show me the mess show me the mess
the
uh
we see the same thing on rogue one right
like when rogue one was coming out that
was gareth edwards project and yeah
there's just a little bit of reshoots
just kind of like people in cockroaches
no my friends you completely changed i
mean solo they couldn't avoid it because
high-profile directors were were fired
mid-production but at least uh rogue one
they they wrapped principal production
and then they brought in tony gilroy to
do the rest of it and then we're able to
figure out from context that like oh
rogue one was mostly tony gilroy's movie
actually because now we're getting
andor and that is a tony gilroy project
so yeah that was mostly his movie hey by
the way i just watched michael clayton
last night and i know it's tony gilbert
movie and i love corporate intrigue
whenever kelly's out of town i'll put on
movies like that that like everyone else
is bored as hell by but i'm like i love
these movies so much it's such a movie
watch michael clayton it's on netflix
no i will not do a michael clayton
breakdown every time i mention like i
love this movie but we're like do a
breakdown of it i'm like no it's like
why can't i just enjoy everything
[Laughter]
no one will watch if i go clayton
breakdown because that'd be so mean to
the subscribers of new rock stars to be
like no i'm not gonna cover um the house
of the dragon trailer that came out a
month ago but here is a michael clayton
breakdown
you should do that on like an april 1st
to scratch an itch but also get away
with it oh i an ultimate what an
ultimate prank um all right we're
running on time empty i gotta ask you do
you think kamal is stuck in the past
here is the bengal broken
i do not think the bengal is broken and
i think that you know this is all part
of like um cause like a while ago samuel
jackson said that captain marvel could
travel through time and people are like
what is he talking about
and like even me
now that we have this time travel thing
happening in miss marvel i'm just
thinking that this has always
been
like something that marvel studios
intended to do with um the blue power of
the marvels and so like i think that
she's not stuck in the past she's
probably going to unlock or figure out
how her bengals able to do this and
travel back to the future um featuring
marty mcfly just kidding um so yeah i
don't think the bengal is broken i think
that um maybe like something within
kamala maybe her fear of being stabbed
activated the time travel mechanic um
because like we see in a multiverse of
madness that um what's her name america
chavez her powers are mainly activated
through emotion and like fear or maybe
even love so it's like i think that's a
very similar thing is happening here
with um kamala um where her fear
probably manifested like all right let's
go through time because we're scared um
but that's just a weird theory uh i
don't think she's like in the past
she'll show you i like that theory i
think that's a great interpretation mt i
love that um my thinking is that uh when
samuel jackson said that quote i agree
it was i love just letting that man talk
because
he it's always fascinating and uh in
this case i was like whoa what is he
talking about i think he was referring
to how like you know how we saw this
kind of time travel from a perspective
conceit in the captain marvel the 2018
captain marvel movie that um that was
through like the scroll memory scrubbing
technology but i think like
the cree people are all about like kind
of shared collective memory and i think
all cretech is kind of rooted it has
stored within it an ability to revisit
memories
uh that's what i think it is i think
what she is now in uh now stuck in is
just a an expanded version of her seeing
the train rushing at her
um
and i think the vision she saw of najma
reaching out toward her i think she it
was really her in her uh
great grandmother's eyes
seeing najma pushing her in front of a
train or pushing her away or something
like that um so i think she is kind of
reliving the past through najma's or
through aisha or sana's perspective
right we did see a mother and daughter
was that meant to be aisha and science
that's what i was doing
at first but i was like it's probably
just some random people just another
another uh family um yeah so i think
it's just the kree tech enables her
ability to revisit these memories i
don't think she is physically stuck in
the past but she is uh like she is kind
of in a trance and right now she's like
laying on the ground in that
market have you played the assistant
break her up i have played the
assassins the animus yes it's like
they're going through like the their
memories like i love that idea
it's it's my favorite part of time
travel uh consciousness uh time travel
it's what we saw in slaughterhouse five
and then in lost with desmond and then
we saw it in dates of future past with
wolverine and i wrote a screenplay in
which a character does this it was the
first screenplay i wrote it made it into
a couple screenwriting contests and it
never got made
but that's okay that's what happens when
you write your first screenplay you
gotta make it yourself i want to see it
no i'll never let anyone read it
don't ask me to read it if anybody asks
me i will not send you that script it's
not very good and there's probably some
jokes in it that like i'm ashamed of now
because you know the jokes one makes in
2012 are not funny in 2022 and they
weren't funny then either i'll tell you
what 2008 like 2006 to 2012 the issue
was a different time
yes yes indeed uh well we will leave it
there for this episode of inside marvel
a great conversation there and mt i love
being able to like unpack this show with
you because like i really appreciate
your perspective
we both kind of see the same kind of
like huh head scratching parts of these
shows but i think ultimately we love
what they're trying to do and i i'm glad
that you and i can talk about it yes we
do love miss marvel and we do we love
everyone involved you guys are doing a
great job and uh don't forget to check
out our integrate merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow mt mastertainment subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcasts thank you for watching and
we'll see you next week bye everybody
you